we got the story from timcast.com
Canadian College threatens Jordan
Peterson's medical license demands
social media Communications training uh
Christopher Bertman wrote this story you
know this this these journalists I got
to tell you here's my headline
suggestion Jordan Peterson threatened
with revocation uh is that the right
word of medical license unless he
submits to re-education yeah I'm just
kidding Chris did a good job we don't we
don't I don't like the the framing but
um in in fact based news but me
personally here's the story that's it
they're saying Jordan Peterson has to
submit to re-education because he's
offended people on social media or
they'll take his medical license away I
say Dr Jordan Peterson
I don't know if he really needs it at
this point I mean I understand he
probably enjoys practicing Clinical
Psychology I think he's probably doing
well for himself and this is an
opportunity to be something bigger than
just a one-on-one doctor again I know I
know it's it's his life it's his career
and everything but I think Jordan
Peterson is better off focused on
telling people to be responsible to be
individuals and things like that but
what again does it say about our society
today that they are literally trying to
take the medical license away from an
individual for nothing more than wrong
whoa whoa hold on hold on hold on hours
aside this is Canada okay
Canada we're well on our way
yep yeah so Jordan Peterson tweeted the
Ontario College of psychologists has
demanded that I submit myself to
mandatory social media Communications
retraining with their experts for among
other crimes retweeting Pierre uh poilev
how do you pronounce it
and criticizing Justin Trudeau and his
political allies amazing about a dozen
people fall over the world submitted
complaints about my public statements on
Twitter and Rogan Over a four-year
period out of 15 million who follow me
on social media claiming that I had
harmed people with My Views not them
he says I've been accused of harming
people uh what does it say uh
I have accused of Harmony people
although none of the complaints involved
clients of mine or anything like that if
I comply with the terms of my
re-education and my pun my punishment
will be announced publicly I have
already had the second most serious
category of punishment levied against me
and I have been deemed at high risk to
re-offend oh my
God I am willing if Ontario CP Ontario
occurs which they won't to make
absolutely every word of all of this
fully public so that everyone can decide
for themselves what is actually
happening here we go man it reminds me
that episode of Simpsons when Homer
makes the Time Machine toaster and he
goes back in time and then he like kills
a mosquito then he goes forward in time
and Ned Flanders controls everything and
then you have to get re-educated and
Flanders but but the reason I bring this
one up is that Flanders is this hokey
nice guy good neighbor but then in this
in this treehouse of Horrors episode
he's an authoritarian so what happens is
you have Canada putting on this air of
We're the nice oh sorry about that you
know we're gonna do a good man make sure
nobody's getting harmed eh better submit
to re-education before you lose your
medical license and have your life
destroyed they were always passive
aggressive I was that niceness was
always fake I was always calling it out
with the Canadians I was I was banned
from Canada aren't you I was banned for
10 years the son of a guns I have to get
a lawyer I fight these wait wait wait
wait a Canadian lawyer ought to go to
Canada why because he's a real American
Girl
you must really like poutine no I didn't
and there was I was dating a chick and I
needed to see her family
[Laughter]
he jumped over the wall and was running
so it feels like I'm thinking like
Einstein before Nazi Germany fled Nazi
Germany before they started cracking
down the Jews and what is Peterson doing
in Canada right now when they're
threatening to strip him of his license
for and I agree with you Tim I don't
think that his that his psychology
license is his crowning achievement even
close to it when history looks at Jordan
Peterson they'll remember the things he
said and things he did he's helping
young people who are lost come back to
responsibility save my life in 2017. I
directly attributed to that man's voice
I I was I was checked out I mean I don't
want to get in I'm not wasting time here
he saved my [ __ ] life dude this guy I
who Jordan yeah
like he just woke up something in my
spirit that reminded me that I have
something to do here isn't that crazy
it's wild it's like this dude who just
comes around and just says find the
heaviest thing you can't you can carry
and carry it
and then all of a sudden he's basically
a father figure to so many people who
did not have a strong masculine presence
but Jordan Peterson is not the most
masculine dude I'm not going to be a
dick like he cries a lot you know what I
mean
he like breaks down and gets made fun of
for crying all the time and he suffers
himself but you have this guy who comes
out and he's just like do it clean your
room and then people are like yeah yeah
and then he writes 600 pages on it and
then does 80 other things and gives
talks and TV shows he's just a
magnificent polymath I like the guy but
maybe it's because of what he's doing
for young men like you like so many
people across the world that's why they
want to silence him you know it's the
same thing that people have said about
like Andrew Tate whether you like him or
not
why is him giving young men confidence
such a thing like to hate him for right
um and it I think it just goes to the
fact that in our society today there's
been such a war on masculinity a war on
strong male role models in so many ways
uh and it leads to things like this or
literally trying to take his medical
license away
um for telling you to clean your room
essentially and for daring to believe in
just common sense and reality but look
look if I'm gonna do it everybody under
the chicken analogy if I went out to
collect the eggs in the chicken coop Kim
does it but you know if I went out there
and there was a rooster that was telling
all the chickens not to let me take the
eggs I'd be upset with that I would I
would remove that riff like I walk in
one day and I'm like where are the eggs
the chickens are all like give me a look
and they're like you can't take the eggs
I'm like what's going on these chickens
standing up for themselves yeah can't
have that get that rooster out of there
that's exactly what it is the
establishment politicians the elites the
corporate Executives the Bill Gates
types don't like the idea that some dude
is rallying people to be individuals to
stand up for themselves no you will owe
nothing and you will be happy then
Jordan Peterson comes around and says
work hard have a family be responsible
for yourself and they're like stop stop
stop yeah shut them up how dare you tell
people to be self-sufficient human
beings and society today well exactly
it's bad for communism yeah if people
are independent you don't get communism
it's bad for the state they need you
weak they need you decide then you do
pathetic and the Canadian government has
been hijacked by the world economic
Forum admittedly even by Klaus Schwab
who said that the organization his young
leaders organization infiltrated more
than half of the parliament inside of uh
the Canadian government and what has the
Canadian government done ever since ever
since being influenced and taken over by
the world economic Forum well uh they
banned a protest they called in a
National Emergency arrested the protest
leaders deep back to them they there
they recently took away guns from from
law-abiding citizens and now there's
re-education camps here I'm seeing a
trend here of what's happening in Canada
and it's not a good one the worst thing
they did was they put a guy in Power who
talks like this and that's funny
everyone we don't need guns that's how
that's how Trudeau talks and that's the
that's the worst thing of it because
like at least Obama was charismatic he'd
step up there and be like hey I'm a
smooth talking celebrity and I'm gonna
blow up kids and you're like that's all
right we're going to hell yeah and he
really doesn't smile it's so weird like
how does he not know that that's weird
he grew up rich insulated with like prep
school and like he's an effeminate soy
boy actor just reading reading the lines
being told what to do implementing the
policies of the great reset that's all
he's doing he's an actor and he's a
great actor and Canadian Parliament is a
performance if you watch those guys
scream and yell and talk over each other
like how are you gonna get so you allow
each other to speak over each other
what's the point of that is have you
seen Paulie ever speak have you seen the
guy oh you should you should watch him
he's definitely gotta he's definitely
got something this is the guy Peterson
shout it out can you imagine Trudeau
when he's like 70. he's gonna be like
Herbert from Family Guy or or exactly
like Phil or exactly like Fidel it's
gonna be funny they're gonna look at his
pictures and be like hey look at the
same guy no but he's gonna be like
Herbert he's gonna be like hey there why
don't you give me your guns give me your
guns little boy how long is this allowed
to be in power according to Canadian
government
the way things are going up there
probably forever he's probably gonna be
Emperor Trudeau and there's going to be
nothing that could stop him you try to
protest him he'll shut it down he'll
take away your bank account he's taken
away people's guns he's taken away
people's ability to have free speech
he's taken away parents ability to
decide what their children should be in
this world so it's it's a Total Takeover
of society total enslavement of humanity
that of course is following the
protocols of Klaus Schwab's great reset
uh they're they're building back better
but they're creating a situation A
dystopian one that really goes and and
and is really surrounding the UN 2030
Vision I spoke very highly of Jordan
Peterson about five minutes ago I'm
gonna criticize Jordan I'm going to
criticize you now because I think what
brought this on is your victory all via
text in social media doesn't translate
the way that voice translates so when
you get angry and you write the angry
things out it's going to tweak people in
a way that your voice won't keep that in
mind moving forward
I like this Jordan Peterson guy pretty
cool you know what I mean that's a good
family too well you know I I think
overall he's a net positive there are
some things to criticize especially with
his relationship with big Pharma
especially with him kind of being a
proponent of of the the coveted vaccine
as well there's there's some things to
to kind of be critical of but at the end
of the day when you look at his kind of
work that he has done I I think it's a
net positive especially with how much he
has influenced young men that didn't
have a role model that didn't have
anyone telling them to clean up their
room to be responsible for themselves uh
so I think with any human being you
can't really judge him you just kind of
gotta uh you know see them for who they
are all right so question when Donald
Trump wins speaker of the house and then
they impeach Biden and Kamala and then
the Senate convicts that convicts them
somehow and that makes Donald Trump
president again do we invade Canada and
liberate it yeah and liberate it now we
will be welcomed as liberators I think
we will that's right yeah we'll come in
the people of Canada scream and cheer as
American tanks roll down their borders
and if we do it right Alberta will just
become a United State and then we'll
continue to expand the United States of
Earth to create a decentralized
organization yeah go back in time to the
war 1812. we almost took uh Quebec yeah
true we like invaded and like went to
Montreal the United States did and then
the British came and burned down the way
I think Canada and the United States is
a great kind of uh experiment because
we're right next to each other
geographically we both speak English for
the most part and our governments are
like different and you see how the
difference is affecting the communities
the way people are being threatened to
lose their license for speaking on
social media again I'm not saying it's
not happening at all in the United
States because Pierre Corey lots of
different scientists were shut down but
I haven't seen that Peter McCall wasn't
stripped of his license for speaking out
against coven but it is crazy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time